I know this one's bad I don't I don't
know how much coming back there is from
this some of YouTube's biggest stars are
weighing in on Shane Dawson getting
straight-up cancelled if you're gonna
cancel someone you better make damn sure
you've never made a mistake in your life
let's rewind real quick remember last
year when Tati Westbrook called out
fellow beauty blogger James Charles in a
43 minute long YouTube video not it all
dramatically titled bye sister well Tati
is now accusing Shane of masterminding
James's 2019 cancellation with the help
of Geoffrey star I can tell you this
it's now my opinion that Geoffrey and
Shane were both bitterly jealous of
James Charles's success
Geoffrey resented that so much of his
business was centered around his biggest
rival and Shane did not like that James
Charles wanted to make a documentary
neither of them were happy with standing
in his shadow on YouTube anymore
naturally Shane was quick to respond and
denied it all on insta live show my god
you are so manipulative your face your
fake crying you are fake crying you
aren't be crying that is not real oh my
god the 31 year old has also come under
fire recently over resurfaced racist and
predatory videos which he apologized for
in a video titled accountability so this
this video is coming from a place of
just wanting to own up to my wanting to
own up to everything I've done on the
internet that has hurt people and as a
result of all of that
several brands have reportedly stopped
working with Shane and YouTube has
demonetized his videos but now some of
Shane's famous YouTube friends are
coming to his defense Brittany Taylor
hit up Twitter detailing a story about
how Shane once gave an iPad to a
stranger claiming he's done countless
things like this with no recognition she
also said he helped her as she left an
abusive relationship quote has he said
and done some really stupid things in
his 20s heck yes I just love my friend
and this is coming from a place of love
I don't offend Shane's underage jokes
and his racist jokes he's my friend I
won't turn it my back on him Trisha
Paytas retweeted Brittany's a lengthy
note and shared her own message of
support quote he is taking care of his
family friends fans and even complete
strangers he's quietly helped to change
lives and no one will ever see that cuz
of his humility
Trisha also posted a 30 minute video to
her YouTube channel
slamming Tati in a video titled Tati
dumb as hell but think of the grand
scheme of things here we are in the
midst of a pandemic of a racial movement
and this girl is concerned about letting
people know that she was she was kind of
pushed into doing a video about James
Charles but to her saltiest thought
you're you were bitter like just see
that Eugenia Cooney who filmed her
return to YouTube with a video on
Shane's channel also backed her friend
tweeting no one deserves to be treated
like that it'll be interesting to see
what Shane Dawson does next I'm I'm
slightly concerned for him because I
know he's a bit more fragile mentally
when nothing's happening even Logan Paul
who has faced his fair share of
controversy in the past weighed in on
his podcast impulsive let me tell you
boy something when you're getting
canceled and the weight of the world is
on your shoulder shoulders and
everyone's spitting on you and saying
hurtful he's going through it right now
he's going through an in a major way and
although obviously I do not agree with
anything he did in the past regarding
his sexual is any of the things you got
Kansas for I do
I do wish Shane strength and getting
through this this too shall pass
hang on and find a way to just improve
and get better
[Music]